[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend den sportlichen Teil der
Sendung hat später Sven Voss auch von
mir guten Abend unsere Themen an diesem
Dienstag
Dynamik in der kampfpanzerdebatte beim
deutschen Leopard könnte es jetzt
schnell gehen Polen beantragt offiziell
die Lieferung an die Ukraine
weniger Geld für Parteien des
Bundesverfassungsgericht kippt die
Erhöhung der staatlichen Parteien
Finanzierung
und Kälterekord in China minus 53 Grad
Celsius lassen das Leben im Nordosten
des Landes förmlich einfrieren
[Musik]
seit Tagen wird in energisch über die
panzerfrage und die zurückhaltende
Position des Bundeskanzlers diskutiert
jetzt kommt offenbar Bewegung in die
Sache zum einen soll laut
Bundesregierung schnell über den Antrag
Polens entschieden werden Leopard
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine zu liefern
und zum anderen rechnet
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius in Kürze
mit einer Entscheidung ob auch
Deutschland Kampfpanzer liefert mehr von
Thomas Reichert
die brisante Anfrage aus Polen landet
heute hier Scharnhorststraße Berlin das
Wirtschaftsministerium lange angekündigt
bittet Warschau nun um Erlaubnis in
Deutschland hergestellte Leopard 2
Panzer an die Ukraine zu liefern und
schickte Anfrage noch ein paar Mahnungen
hinterher
ich hoffe dass die Antwort aus
Deutschland dieses mal schnell kommt
denn die deutschen zögern weichen aus
und verhalten sich auf eine Art und
Weise die schwer zu verstehen ist
in Berlin heißt es der Antrag werde mit
der gebotenen Dringlichkeit geprüft bis
dahin muss Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius tun was er seit Tagen tut er
muss vertrösten die Öffentlichkeit und
auch den Nato-Generalsekretär die Frage
nach den Leopard Panzern es gibt noch
keinen neuen stand ich habe immer gesagt
ich rechne damit das in Kürze eine
Entscheidung fällt und davon gehe ich
nach wie vor aus Stoltenberg die
Deutschen für ihre Hilfen und drängt zu
mir freundlich doch unverblümt
entscheidenden Moment des Krieges müssen
wir der Ukraine schwerere und modernere
Systeme zur Verfügung stellen und wir
müssen es schneller tun
der Druck auf Deutschland ist enorm und
vieles deutet darauf hin dass eine
Entscheidung unmittelbar bevorsteht
treffen müsste sie am Ende Kanzler
Scholz
deswegen erwarten wir jetzt vom
Bundeskanzler das schnell diese Signale
in Richtung Polen gesendet werden dass
diese Lieferung der Panzer aus Polen
heraus an die Ukraine möglich ist AFD
und Linke sind gegen Panzerlieferungen
sie fürchten eine Ausweitung des Krieges
auf eine ätherischen Viktor Ukraine zu
pochen ist unverantwortlich denn Fakt
ist Russland ist als Atom macht
militärisch nicht besiegbar eben auch
nicht mit modernen Kampfpanzern morgen
wird Scholz im Bundestag Rede und
Antwort stehen gut möglich dass es dann
schon mehr Klarheit gibt
mehrfach hat Kanzler Scholz ja betont
wie wichtig es sei sich bei
kampfpanzerlieferungen mit dem
mächtigsten Nato-Partner den USA
abzustimmen fragen wir nach in
Washington bei Elma teven Elmar die USA
haben sich in der panzerfrage ja lange
gezielt aber auch dort sagt man soll es
Bewegung geben was hören Sie
ja mehrere amerikanische Medien
berichten übereinstimmend unter Berufung
auf Quellen in der US-Regierung dass die
USA bereit sind Abrams Panzer in die
Ukraine zu liefern man hat in den
letzten Tagen so hören wir gemeinsam
miteinander beraten und arbeitet an
einer Vereinbarung an der die letzten
Details noch geklärt werden und die
letzte Entscheidung liegt natürlich dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten aber es sieht
so aus als würden die USA Abrams Panzer
in die Ukraine liefern eben auch um den
Weg frei zu machen für Deutschland und
andere um Leopard 2 dorthin zu liefern
der demokratische republikanische
Senatorin Graham hat vorhin noch einmal
gesagt dies ist ein Moment für
Deutschland zu glänzen und sich als
Kraft für das Gute zu beweisen und hier
rechnet man den Washington damit dass
Deutschland morgen tatsächlich diesen
Tag haben wird und dass die USA eben
bereits sind auch Abrams Panzer in die
Ukraine zu liefern frische Informationen
aus den USA live aus Washington war das
vielen Dank Elmar es ist also gerade
wirklich viel Bewegung drin rund um die
Panzerlieferungen und das ist wollen wir
auch besprechen in einer ZDF heute live
um 19 Uhr auf ZDF heute und auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und morgen nach der
19 Uhr heute Sendung steht der
Bundeskanzler Rede und Antwort in was
nun Herr Scholz
Leben in Deutschland war zuletzt teuer
das ist es eigentlich immer noch und
wird es auch wohl bleiben und darum
fordern die Gewerkschaften für die
Beschäftigten von Bund und Kommunen ein
zweistelliges Lohn plus eine so hohe
Forderung hat seit Jahrzehnten nicht
mehr gegeben schauen wir auf zwei
wichtige Abschlüsse die es zuletzt
gegeben hat in der Chemie und
Pharmaindustrie da gab es im Herbst
6,5% mehr Lohn ein Plus von insgesamt
8,5% kam in der Metall und
Elektroindustrie heraus für die
Beschäftigten im öffentlichen Dienst
liegen die Beförderungen jetzt noch
höher bei 10,5 % manche klingenball
sie arbeiten im öffentlichen Dienst und
heute sind sie laut für Lohnerhöhungen
im Bereich der Pflege muss man sagen
ähnlich gerade so großzügig bestimmt das
ist für viele Leute ob wir uns in der
Pflege gerade dafür aussieht das ist zu
reicht die Mieten die nehmen Kosten
alles zu tragen ihre Jobs sind einfach
zu schlecht bezahlt finden Sie Verdi und
Beamtenbund fordernd für gut 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigte eine Erhöhung der
Entgelte um 10,5% mindestens aber um 500
Euro monatlich bei 12 Monaten Laufzeit
Auszubildende und Praktikanten sollen
200 Euro mehr bekommen es sind die
höchsten Forderungen seit Jahrzehnten
doch die Inflation führe zu einer harten
sozialen Schieflage so Verdi wir gucken
auf einen Tarifabschluss aus dem Jahr
2020 seitdem sind die Preise um 11%
gestiegen die Einkommen im öffentlichen
Dienst aber nur zwischen drei und vier
Prozent allein das müssen wir aufholen
in dieser Tarifrunde und die Preise
steigen weiter die kommunalen
Arbeitgeber halten dagegen ein Teil der
hohen Preise werde mittlerweile ja auch
schon aufgefangen es gab zahlreiche
entlastungspakete die muss man erstmal
den Inflationen gegenrechnen und wir
müssen natürlich auch in die Zukunft
schauen Unwegbarkeiten und
Unsicherheiten ist meine These diese
zehn Komma die von den berndianern
angeführt werden die sind schon lange
nicht mehr Realität
bislang gibt es von der Arbeitgeberseite
kein Angebot
jetzt geht es um Parteien und sehr viel
Geld es ging zu schnell es war zu
unkonkret begründet und zu weitreichend
das höchste deutsche Gericht hat
geurteilt und die Erhöhung der
staatlichen Parteienfinanzierung für
verfassungswidrig erklärt dazu gleich
mehr zuvor erklärt Christoph destovell
kurz was über Parteienfinanzierung
wissen sollten
wie viel Geld Parteien vom Staat
bekommen das hängt Zitat aus dem
zuständigen Gesetz von ihrer
Verwurzelung in der Gesellschaft ab die
wird vor allem am Wahlergebnis gemessen
alle Parteien die bei Bundestags oder
Europawahlen über 0,5% Stimmanteil
kommen oder bei Landtagswahlen über ein
Prozent werden gefördert pro Stürme gibt
es grob vereinfacht knapp ein Euro
der Staat belohnt die Parteien aber auch
für das Geld dass sie selbst über
Beiträge und Spenden verdient haben pro
eingenommenen Euro legt er 45 Cent drauf
sicherheitshalber sind bei dieser
doppelten Förderung zwei Bremsen
eingebaut keine Partei bekommt mehr Geld
dazu als sie selbst erwirtschaftet hat
und pro Jahr gilt für alle zusammen eine
absolute Obergrenze wird dieses Limit
überschritten und das passiert meist
werden die Zuwendungen an die Parteien
entsprechend gekürzt genau diese
Obergrenze hatte der Bund 2018 erheblich
angehoben zuletzt lag sie bei 205,1
Millionen Euro
und beschlossen wurde die jetzt gekippte
Erhöhung der Parteienfinanzierung vor
viereinhalb Jahren von der groko
innerhalb von zehn Tagen und während der
Fußball-WM 2018 wurde das Gesetz durchs
Parlament gepeitscht und auch
beschlossen über das Urteil und was
davon ausgeht Sarah Tacke
Parteien im Wahlkampf beim Bürger vor
Ort präsent mit Werbegeschenken und
Flyern und parallel auch im Netz dieses
Arbeiten zeitgleich in der digitalen und
analogen Welt kostet viel Geld deshalb
hatten CDU und SPD den staatlichen Teil
der Parteienfinanzierung deutlich erhöht
per Gesetz 2018 weitgehend unbemerkt im
Schatten der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
das könnte noch Selbstbedienung Aussehen
fürchteten die damaligen
Oppositionsparteien klagten und bekamen
hier heute recht
die angegriffene Norm verstößt gegen den
Grundsatz der staatsfreiheit der
Parteien weil der Gesetzgeber nicht
ausreichend dargelegt hat dass der
zusätzliche aus eigenen Mitteln nicht
aufzubringen der Finanzbedarf der
politischen Parteien eine Anhebung der
absoluten Obergrenze um knapp 25
Millionen Euro erfordert eine schallende
Ohrfeige für Union und SPD
diesen Ruf des ungerichts haben wir sehr
wohl gehört und werden darauf aufbauend
jetzt mit den anderen Parteien versuchen
zeitnah zusammenzukommen und zu
beratschlagen wie ist jetzt weitergehen
kann offen ist noch ob die Parteien das
zu viel erhaltene Steuergeld
zurückzahlen müssen klar ist hingegen ab
sofort müssen alle Parteien mit weniger
Geld auskommen
und Richter hier im
bundesverfassungsrecht in Karlsruhe
haben heute ganz deutlich Stopp gesagt
so schnell und vor allem so schlecht
begründet dürfen Parteien sich nicht
einfach ihre Mittel erhöhen denn wenn
der Eindruck entsteht Parteien würden
sich selbst bedienen dann schadet das
dem Vertrauen in Parteien und damit am
Ende auch unserer Demokratie ein
zentrales Grundsatzurteil das mehr
Klarheit über die Finanzierung von
Parteien in Deutschland schafft
in Zeiten des ukrainekrieges bemühen
sich Deutschland und Frankreich einen
anderen gefährlichen Konflikt zu
entschärfen es geht um Serbien und
Kosovo Kosovo wird mehrheitlich von
Albanern bewohnt hat sich nach einem
blutigen Krieg 2008 von Serbien
losgesagt und für unabhängig erklärt und
dagegen wehrt sich Belgrad jetzt erhöht
der Westen den diplomatischen Druck
Serbien soll die Beziehung normalisieren
sonst drohe das aus in Sachen
EU-Beitritt und der Abzug von
Investitionen Britta Hilbert berichtet
es war wieder so ein Vorfall der den
Frieden gefährdet zwischen Kosovo und
Serbien dieser Serbe wurde angeschossen
bei einer kosovarischen Polizei
Kontrolle doch Serbiens Präsident Vucic
reagiert unerwartet er verkündet dass es
trotzdem vorangehen soll im
Friedensprozess die EU drängt darauf der
Faktor
er müsse den Friedensplan akzeptieren so
Vucic gestern abend spät sonst würden
die Beitrittsverhandlungen zur EU
unterbrochen und Investitionen
eingestellt
integratia noch im Dezember sah alles
nach Krieg aus im Norden des Kosovo
Bauten Serben Blockaden oh Schüsse viel
Kosovo will das Serbien seine
Unabhängigkeit anerkennt der Krieg in
der Ukraine befeuert den Konflikt
Serbien verweigert Sanktionen gegen das
russische Bruder Volk Putin unterstützt
Serbiens Ansprüche auf das Kosovo doch
serbien will auch EU-Mitglied werden
der Wirtschaft wegen in Kriegszeiten
kommt seine jahrelange
ost-west-schaukelpolitik unter Druck die
EU will jetzt wissen wer für Sie ist und
wer nicht der Druck von USA und EU haben
bei wucic gewirkt die Frage ist für wie
lange es ist eine rhetorische Wende ein
erster Schritt es wird viel wirklich vom
Druck des Westens vom nachhaltigen Druck
des Westens abhängig und so pendeln die
Diplomaten weiter auch ins Kosovo von
dort noch keine Reaktion man traut den
Frieden wohl noch nicht
zurück nach Deutschland seit Jahren
ringt die CDU mit ihrem Parteimitglied
Hans-Georg Maaßen jetzt prüft die Partei
ein Ausschlussverfahren gegen den
früheren verfassungsschutzchef
Hintergrund sind aktuelle
Interviewäußerungen darin sprach Maaßen
so wörtlich von einer rot-grünen
Rassenlehre nach der weiße als
minderwertige Rasse angesehen werden
Generalsekretär Chaya forderte Maaßen
auf die CDU von sich aus zu verlassen
anlässlich des 70-jährigen Bestehens der
Holocaust-Gedenkstätte javasem werden
zum ersten Mal Ausstellungsstücke in
Deutschland gezeigt genauer im Bundestag
16 an der Zahl 1 für jedes Bundesland
und hinter jedem Exponat steht eine
berührende Geschichte mehr zu diesem
historisch sensiblen geschichts- und
Kulturprojekt von Winnie Häscher
eine Puppenküche aus Keramik Anneliese
Dreifuß nahm sie als Kind mit ins
amerikanische Exil als sie 1939 mit
ihrem Vater Stuttgart verließ
einen kanukalleuchter mitgenommen von
der rabbi-familie Posner auf der Flucht
von Kiel nach Belgien 1934 ein Foto
zeigt wo der Leuchter ursprünglich in
ihrer Wohnung stand eine
nsdap-geschäftsstelle gegenüber
sogar ein Klavier konnte von Berlin nach
Palästina in Sicherheit gebracht werden
16 Gegenstände die Opfern des Holocaust
gehörten zeigt die Ausstellung der
Leiter der Gedenkstätte hat verschämt
dann in der jan hat sie von Jerusalem
hierher begleitet der 67-Jährige ist zum
ersten Mal in Deutschland er wollte nie
herkommen wegen der Erinnerung nun ist
er da wegen der Erinnerung
wir sind in einem Wettlauf mit der Zeit
die Erinnerungen aufzunehmen vom
Zeitzeugen von Überlebenden
[Musik]
diese Gelegenheit nicht hatten auch
diese Gegenstände hier sind ihr Zeugnis
wichtigste ist eben diesen Opfer Namen
und Geschichten zu geben und durch das
Gedenken immer an die Zukunft denken
jede Generation muss sich neu mit den
Menschheitsverbrechen des Holocaust
auseinandersetzen 16 Gegenstände von
Menschen die hier in Deutschland eins zu
Hause waren es sind kleine Dinge ihres
Lebens die große Geschichten erzählen
wenn Wasser wie hier schon in der Luft
gefriert dann ist es richtig kalt im
Norden Chinas ist es gerade kälter als
minus 50 Grad und endlose Winter kennen
sie da aber das was die Menschen an der
Grenze zu Russland jetzt gerade erleben
ist sogar für sie ungewöhnlich Elisabeth
Schmidt berichtet von dieser Isis Kälte
arbeiten wie in der Tiefkühltruhe
möglichst viel bewegen bloß nicht
einfrieren auch bei der
Warmwasserleitung muss nachgeholfen
werden noch nie ist es so kalt gewesen
in China
diese Reporterin führt die eisigen
Temperaturen live im Staatsfernsehen vor
schaut euch dieses Ei an sagt sie es
gefriert innerhalb weniger Sekunden
der Volksrepublik an der Grenze zu
Russland und wird auch Chinas Arktis
statt genannt bis zu 8 Monate im Jahr
liegt hier Schnee aber so frostige
Temperaturen haben sie auch hier noch
nicht erlebt so Ciao wir stehen hier
unter dem Einfluss ultra kalter polarer
Luft die Temperatur liegt jetzt den
dritten Tag in Folge unter minus 50 Grad
am Morgen dann der neue Kälterekord
minus 53 Grad
zum Social Media Trend geworden Menschen
Spritzen heißes Wasser in die Luft und
tanzen dann durch die Eiskristalle so
schön können minus 53 Grad aussehen
sehr kalt aber sehr schicke Bilder es
werden jetzt machen wir weiter mit Sport
und es wird ernst für die deutschen
Handballer ja das kann man wohl sagen
morgen das WM-Viertelfinale gegen
Olympiasieger Frankreich live im ZDF und
das Team von Bundestrainer Alfred
gießlersson ist bereit die erste
turnierliga Lage gestern kratzte nur
ganz kurz am Selbstbewusstsein
die Mine noch immer etwas mürrisch am
Mittag bei der Ankunft in Danzig
Deutschland gestern Abend nach der
ersten und einzigen Führung 8 Minuten
lang ohne eigenen Treffer die Niederlage
daher vermeidbar aber auch zu
verschmerzen vielleicht ein Dämpfer zur
rechten Zeit das ist natürlich die
Hoffnung dass wir dadurch
sehen dass man sich vielleicht die ein
oder andere Gedanke noch mehr machen
sollte am Nachmittag trifft er nach
nominierte Kreisläufer Tim Zechel im
Hotel ein dort wo sich beide Teams beim
Essen schon mal beschnuppern können
Rekordweltmeister Frankreich bisher ohne
Niederlage ein Team das kaum
Schwachstellen hat aber wir sind noch
nicht in die Analyse eingestiegen aber
es ist natürlich schon so das ist eine
individuelle Weltklasse besetzte
Mannschaft ist sie wollten sie nur nicht
verraten
genau
dann hoffen wir mal dass es bei der
Videoanalyse keinen Lauschangriff gibt
us-skirennfahrerin Micaela shiffrin hat
wieder Sportgeschichte geschrieben mit
ihrem Erfolg beim Riesenslalom am
Kronplatz in Südtirol vor die 27-Jährige
ihren 83 Weltcup-Sieg ein Rekord
shiffrin hat damit Lindsey Vonn als
alpine skikönigin abgelöst
und zum deutschen Rekordmeister Bayern
München trifft heute Abend auf den
ersten fC Köln beim Tabellenführer
herrscht Unruhe nach der überraschenden
Trennung von Torwarttrainer Toni
tabalovic ein funktionierendes Trio
waren sie wohl nicht Alexander Nübel
hinter Kollege neuer und Trainer
tabalovic der hatte über lange Jahre
eine freundschaftliche Beziehung zum
Nationaltorhüter aufgebaut Nübel
ausgeliehen nach Monaco brachte die
Dinge aus seiner Sicht auf den Punkt ich
glaube schon dass man ab und zu sich
austauschen hätte können über die
Situation wie es wie es läuft aber es
war es war nicht der Fall offenbar hatte
auch Trainer nagelsmann Vorbehalte
Tapalovic soll seinem intimus
vertrauliches aus der trainerkabine
weitergegeben haben die Trennung folgte
rasch insbesondere Differenzen über die
Art und Weise der Zusammenarbeit haben
jetzt dazu geführt dass wir getrennte
Wege gehen
Nachfolger soll der ehemalige Bayern
Schluss machen und Nachwuchstrainer Tom
stark gewähren
und das war der Sport für heute dann
vielen Dank Sven wie bzw ob das
Winterwetter weitergeht gleich mit Katja
horneffer
Christian Sievers meldet sich um 21 Uhr
mit dem heute-journal das war es von uns
wir sagen danke fürs zuschauen gerne bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht bildet sich mal
wieder dicker Nebel und wenn es mal
aufklar hat dann wird es sofort eisig
dann sinken die Temperaturen bis minus 6
Grad am oberrheine plus 3 Grad
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen meist
ganz knapp im Plus dauerfrostlich bleibt
es über Schnee an den Alpen mit -1 Grad
die mildesten Temperaturen finden sich
am Mittel und am Oberrhein mit vier bis
sechs Grad und auch der Tag morgen wird
wieder sehr früh vielleicht sehen sie im
Alpenrand oder im Bayerischen Wald im
Sauerland oder an der Ostsee mal kurz
die Sonne für die meisten wird das aber
ein drüber Tag und dann wird spannend in
der Nacht zu Donnerstag denn da zieht
ein kleines Regenwald daran Regen das
ist bei uns blau eingefärbt und das
bedeutet zunächst mal gefrieren den
Regen im Laufe des Donnerstags wird aus
diesem Regen Schnee bei uns zu rosa
eingefärbt und der zieht dann weiter
nach Südosten machen Sie sich also in
der Nacht auf Donnerstag und Donnerstag
am frühen Morgen im Nordwesten auf
gefährliche Straßenglätte gefasst am
Freitag gibt es dann noch Schneeregen in
Sachsen und Schnee in Bayern das
Wochenende wird deutlich ruhiger mit
Regen im Nordwesten guten Abend